there's a lot at stake right now in the
presidential election if joe biden pulls
this one out
he's going to empower this bureaucratic
blob the deep state the administrative
state
and all these little experts are going
to write lots of laws well
past the holes of congress they're going
to write it in the epa
or in the fda or wherever and all the
alphabet agencies
to run your life for you and they're
going to try to to steal it
if they don't win it outright they'll
try to steal it maybe you heard the
story actually you did because i
mentioned it on the show the other day
the other day postal worker comes out
and alleges fraud
alleges that his supervisor told him
pick up ballots that are illegal
deliver them to me so then the
washington post came out and said
not true this postal worker has recanted
this is
fake news don't spread this story well
now i guess that was supposed to be the
end of the story except that the postal
worker came out and he said
i absolutely did not recant and the
washington post is lying about me
i am right at this very moment looking
at a
article written written by washington
post
says that i uh fabricated the
allegations
of ballot tampering i'm here to say that
i did not recant
my statements that did not happen that's
not what happened
and you will find out tomorrow so we'll
find out he's going to release a longer
video about this
but it didn't happen now i don't i don't
know
the entirety of his story but what i do
know is something that i've known for a
long time
that the washington post is lying about
it the entire establishment press
which is tied into the establishment
academy which is tied into the
establishment
popular culture which is tied into the
establishment technology which is
tied into the established administrative
government and elected politicians
that is what is trying to win this
election it is not about joe biden
joe biden is nothing he is totally
hollow
if you crack him open he you would you
would find air leaking out there is
nothing inside he's been an empty suit
his whole career the same goes for
kamala harris
she's she's articulated more forcefully
certain views it's only
because she's younger i think she licks
her finger puts it up in the air
figures out which way the wind is
blowing okay now there are
politicians on the left who have strong
views
they will be pulling the strings joe
biden has already admitted as much he's
moved so radically to the left
just in the issue of abortion he used to
oppose abortion
now he not only doesn't oppose it he
supports taxpayer-funded abortion
with no restrictions there are
these uh strong-minded characters on the
left one of them would be stacy abrams
who is just as much the governor of
georgia as joe biden as the
president-elect
stacey abrams you remember her she's
come out and said forget this moderation
talk
forget this talk about the american
ideals what we need
is identity politics identity politics
is exactly who we are
and it's exactly how we won identity
politics
that's exactly how we won identity
politics that's how
the left win now the trouble of course
with this is the left
didn't just win the election the left
was supposed to be a blue wave remember
the left was supposed to take the senate
doesn't look like they did that
and the left was supposed to win big
seats in the house didn't do that they
lost seats in the house
they may have lost a lot of seats in the
house and they were playing those
identity politics
identity politics is
fundamentally opposed to the american
and broader western political tradition
because what identity politics says is
we need to set up essentially a sort of
caste
system in america and we're going to
judge people based on
their their oppression their perceived
oppression whether that's real or
imagined
and we're going to give people certain
privileges so for instance we're going
to give
black people certain privileges in
university admissions and
job hiring and they're going to get
those privileges because of the legacy
of slavery
now you might ask what about black
people who do not descend from slaves
like for instance barack obama or kamala
harris
both of whom descended not from slaves
but from slave owners
do they have a disadvantage are they
oppressed
neither of those people seem
particularly oppressed to me one was the
president one might possibly become the
vice president she's a sitting u.s
senator
i don't i don't think are they how are
they oppressed well because of their
identity not because of the facts of
their life but because
of their identity pits uh americans
against one another
and pits all americans against their own
history that's the point
and identity politics unfortunately is
very effective and what's interesting is
for all the talk of white supremacy and
white nationalism these sorts of things
white people in america have a very very
low racial consciousness there was a
report came out i think from pew
research that showed that for
every major ethnic group racial
consciousness ranks
above 50 percent that is more greater
than 50
of respondents said that their race is
very important to their identity
for black people this was the strongest
uh followed by hispanics and asians
for white people racial identity was 15
it's way way way way low which is
perfectly fine by me i when you if you
were to ask me michael who are you what
are you what would i say i'm
catholic i'm uh american
i'm sicilian you know i get a little of
that i got i guess i've got some english
in there
i'm a cigar smoker i'm a joker i'm a
smoker i'm a midnight toker right i'd
give like
and and white guy would be somewhere
pretty far down on the list
but what stacey abrams is saying is no
you're a white guy buddy
white white is number one your racial
identity which
she is constructing for us that has got
to be number one
now that kind of radical politics didn't
win the last election i mean
would you say identity politics is how
we won how'd you win the guy that you
may be elected president is the oldest
whitest dude
in america right so i i don't if that's
the identity i guess then the democrats
are going back to their roots
but in the future perhaps it will work i
mean there is something to this idea
and michael moore was saying this
democrats need to become socialist they
need to just admit that they're
socialists
stop pretending they're not socialists
and he's been harangued for this but
michael moore
actually gets politics pretty well he
was one of the few people on the left
who called trump
and there is a phenomenon going on right
now my friend spencer clavin over at
claremont and the american mind he
pointed this out to me the other day we
were discussing the woke people
and the red-pilled conservatives and the
you know
the idea that the kind of establishment
consensus on both the left and the right
are cracking
and he said well michael isn't it
interesting that the two terms that
we're using
for people who realize that the old
consensus is broken and that some new
kind of political coalition needs to
form
on the left we say they're woke and on
the right we say they're
red-pilled and both terms imply
a kind of waking up out of a dream-like
state
waking up and seeing reality anew for
the first time and i think there's
something to that
i think democrats have behaved like
socialists for a very long time and they
just haven't admitted it to themselves
and i think that conservatives have
convinced themselves of a lot of
sort of slogans and bumper stickers that
aren't necessarily true
and they they they tilt against
windmills and they
fight with that they fight battles that
no one really cares about
you know uh it's perfectly fine the
liberal establishment is perfectly fine
to have conservatives arguing for low
taxes sometimes the liberal
establishment doesn't even mind the low
taxes but the minute you bring up
culture the minute you bring up mass
migration the minute you bring up love
of country even all of a sudden that's a
little bit
too much if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
you never miss another video